about um instance optimal iterative
methods for Matrix function
approximation it's not directly an
optimization talk but it'll relate a lot
to uh iterative methods for linear
solvers and types of stuff that you guys
have probably seen before so this is
Joint work with no amsel he's a student
of my brothers at NYU Tyler Chen who's a
postto of my brothers at NYU he's on the
job market this year um and green bom at
University of Washington and my brother
Chris MCO at
NYU all right so the basic problem we're
considering is I have some scalar
function f it Maps real values to real
values and I'm applying I want to apply
this to a matrix what does that mean um
if I have a symmetric Matrix a it has
some igen decomposition The Matrix
function f of a is just I apply F to
each igen value and I reweight the
components of the Matrix applying F to
each igen value so another way to think
about this I take my hen decomposition
in the diagonal igen value Matrix I just
entrywise apply the Matrix function f
okay I'm only going to talk about
symmetric matrices in this entire talk
and symmetric real
matrices what we want to do is we want
to compute The Matrix Vector product F
of a times B okay I don't want to
compute all of f of a I just want to
multiply F of a times a vector
understand it's action on a vector now
for General a like unless I have a lot
of structure um exact computation of
this is not really possible but like
very high accuracy computation
essentially requires if I want to just
directly compute it I basically need to
do a full igen decomposition Rew the
igen decomposition it takes me something
like n Cub or n the Omega time um so
what we want to do is we want
approximation algorithms that are a lot
faster than this
okay so that's the
problem why do I care about this problem
it has tons of applications the one you
guys have probably seen the most is when
f ofx is one overx then F of a is just
the Matrix inverse in F of a in in F of
a Time B is just the solution to a
linear system okay so this is by far
part of the most well studied version of
this
problem another example would be like
let's say a is PSD so it has all non-
negative igen values um and F is the
square root function then F of a is just
the Matrix square root uh this is used
for example if I want to sample from a
multivariate gaussian distribution with
coari a I would want to multiply the
square root times isotropic Gan Vector
so that would be one application of the
Matrix square root but there's a ton of
applications of Matrix square root um
another time we care about Matrix
functions is sort of computing the
traces of Matrix functions so the trace
of the Matrix function f of a is just
the sum of its values or in other words
it's the sum of f of the IG values so
for example if f ofx is log of x then
trace of f of a is just the sum of the
logs of the I values which is like the
log determinant and this shows up a lot
for example in like uh log probabilities
and Basi optimization all sorts of
places okay now this is a little bit
different Computing the trace is
different than than multiplying F uh the
matrix by a vector but you can estimate
the trace just by repeatedly multiplying
the function by random vectors like uh
this is what Hutchinson's method does so
if I want to do Trace estimation on a
matrix function which I often want to do
the first perimeter I look for is can I
at least multiply this function by
vectors all right that's the problem any
oh oh let me just mention some other
examples that come up the Matrix sign
function other step functions or
spectral winding functions The Matrix
exponential
I already mentioned the Matrix square
root but either way there's a lot of
these functions that come up in lots of
different applications so before I move
on any questions about the problem I'm
solving or the
motivation okay
awesome so how do we approximate Matrix
function times vectors um almost always
people use what are known as krov
Subspace methods the key idea here is
that let's say F was a degree Q polom in
this case I can compute F of a I can
multiply more it can't really be
computed but I can multiply F of a by a
vector using just Q Matrix Vector
products with a and so my runtime even
if a was like totally unstructured and
dense would be something like n s time Q
if a was sparse or structured it could
have been faster so why can I do this F
of a Time B is just like some
coefficient times B plus some confition
times a a s b Etc so I just compute one
Matrix Vector product to get a
a second one to get a s b i just build
up these products right so if F was a
polinomial I'd be in good shape as long
as the degree is not too large I need to
do Q Matrix Vector products with my
Matrix which should be pretty
fast so the whole idea of kroff methods
is just approximate General functions
with pols and then use this above fact
to compute them quickly that's the whole
idea and they're the main method we have
for approximating Matrix
functions in this talk I'm going to
focus entirely on a specific krog method
called the Lantos method which I'll tell
you what it is in a second um and it can
be used to approximate any F OFA in some
sense optimally although I'm going to
talk about why the sense of optimal is
maybe not
satisfactory um just to note just so you
like have a frame of reference if a was
positive F definite if F was one overx
this Lantos method I'm going to discuss
gives exactly the same output as the
conent gradient algorithm it's slightly
different algorithm in finite Precision
will behave slightly differently but
they're mathematically equivalent
algorithms
okay other examples of kop Subspace
methods you might have heard of that I'm
not really going to focus on in this
talk minres for solving non PSD systems
gradient descent accelerated gradient
descent pretty much almost all
non-stochastic iterative methods for
solving linear systems can be a lot of
EX contr have Subspace methods
okay
okay so what's the Lanos method this is
an awesome algorithm it's really simple
um it's used for Matrix function
approximation for igen Value
approximation it's all over the place
and it has a fairly simple idea so I'm
going to run it for K iterations it's an
iterative method I'll use K minus one
Matrix sector products and what this
method will do is it'll compute an
orthonormal basis q that spans the krov
Subspace b a a s b Etc so in in other
words the column span of Q is basically
all possible degree K or degree K minus
one pols multiplied by my Vector that
that's the column span of
Q the method orales Q the Lantos part of
this method orthogonalize Q via Tri term
recurrence it ensures this sort of nice
property which is that if I look at Q
transpose AQ which is kind of like the
projection of a Down onto the Q space
this is actually a triagonal matrix
okay and what we're going to do is we're
going to approximate F of a so I have a
this big Matrix I want to compute F of
a I'm gonna approximate this as
Q so Q is K by n where K is the number
of
iterations times F of T where T is this
little triagonal
Matrix times Q
transpose okay so that's the whole
method it's kind of totally agnostic to
the function you're approximating in the
sense that you just the only place F
comes in is you apply F to T okay but
other than that the me the method's
totally
generic okay questions on that so far
I'll give you the motivation behind this
method in a
second okay so like why are we doing
this I mean this looks a little bit
crazy what's going on
here oh actually before I say why I'll
just say at least we can do this quickly
so F of t because T is triagonal you can
like compute its I decomposition really
quickly so you can compute F of T
essentially exactly in K squ time which
the number of iterations Will typically
be less than your problem size this
would be less than like NK time where n
is the is the size of the original
Matrix so the total runtime of this
method is very small it requires like K
Matrix Vector products with a and then
roughly like K other Matrix Vector
operations so this second term like NK
is usually considered lower order this
is just for like adding together vectors
at each
iteration okay so it's fast but why are
we doing
it the motivation behind this method is
that it's exact for pols so what I can
observe is that let's say I take a pol
or let's say I just take a monomial a to
the I where I is less than my number of
iterations
K A to the I *
B is equal to QQ transpose a to the I *
B because spans this krof Subspace a to
the I * B is in that krof Subspace so
when I project onto the krof Subspace
it's a no OPP it's it's just
equal B is also in the krov Subspace
it's the first Vector so QQ transpose B
is equal to B so a to the I times B is
equal to basically the AI projected on
both sides by QQ transpose times B and
this is exactly equal to the Lantos
approximation this is equal to q t to
the Q transpose B that's because T is
equal to basically like
Q transpose a
q so if I raise this to the ith power I
get like Q transpose a q transpose QA
like a bunch of times all these middle
terms cancel out and I just get two
transpose a to the
I okay so this is T to the I okay so for
a monomial this this method is exact
okay and then by linearity it's actually
exact for all pols of degree less than K
so if the polinomial is degree less than
K and I apply Lantos to approximate it
it's
exact okay so that's sort of the
motivation behind this method any
questions on
that okay now why is this like cool via
triangle inequality you can use this to
get a really nice error Bound for
approximating General Matrix
functions so let's just assume for
scaling so I don't want because I don't
want to write it down that the L2 Norm
of B is always one so it'll disappear in
my
equations if I have a polom of degree
less than K I can write the error of
Lanos so basically my exact Matrix
function minus the
approximation via triangle inequality is
the error in applying the
polom plus the difference between the
polom and my actual function right
oh I wrote I underlined the wrong thing
this is the difference between the
polinomial and my actual function and
this is the error and applying oh I said
it again wrong again sorry sorry okay I
if I can write basically the error of
Lanos as um the error of applying the
polinomial plus the difference in my
function with the polinomial on my
original Matrix plus the difference in
the approximation for the polinomial and
the approximation for my original
function fun okay so there's three terms
there but this first term is zero
because there's no error in applying the
poal right so the error of applying a
general function is just the difference
between that function and the polinomial
on a and on my approximation like on
t b is unit Norm Q is an orthonormal
Matrix so this is basically the spectral
Norm difference between my function
applied to a and the polinomial applied
to a plus my function applied to T and
the polinomial applied to
T or another way to think about it is
these matrices have all the same igen
vectors they just have different igen
values so basically the maximum over all
my igen values of a of the function
minus the polinomial plus the maximum of
all the IG values of T of the function
minus
polom or if I want to write this in a
nice way the igen values of T by
interlacing are bounded within the range
of the igen values of a so if I want to
give it an upper bound on this this is
at almost two times the maximum
difference of my polinomial in my
function over my full range of I
values
okay this holds for any polinomial P so
if I just optimize overall pols what I
get is that the error of Lanos and
approximating this Matrix function is at
most two times the best polom for
approximating my function over all the
values in my value
range or if you want to say not in math
lrs gives within a two factor of the
best uniform approximation error of f by
a polinomial on a spectral range this is
really nice basically the better f is
approximated by a polinomial the better
Lantos performs and this is why Lantos
sort of works well for approximating
Matrix
functions so any questions just about
this error
guarantee silly question but is the two
needed uh yeah uh wait no I don't know
if the two is needed actually I mean
there's there's examples where this is
tight up to a factor of two um yeah I
don't know good
question other questions on
this okay let me just remark some things
on this this is a very powerful
convergence bound one thing you could do
to use use it to show is for example
like we know that like conri and
gradient or like other like kind of
optimal kov methods they could they can
solve linear systems to accuracy Epsilon
and roughly like square root condition
number log one over Epsilon iterations
this uniform approximation bound would
be enough to show that you just show you
can approximate the inverse function
with a polinomial degree roughly root
condition number this guarantees robust
to roundoff error so Lanos methods are
inherently very sensitive to roundoff
error in the sense that if I have
roundoff error like Q will often be very
far from or than normal
but you can still show that this
guarantee holds up to a small factor
which is really nice um and related to
rasmus's question this is tight up to a
factor of two for any continuous
function f and for worst case A and B
even when your Matrix size is pretty
small even when n is just K plus one one
more than your number of iterations you
can kind of find a worst case BNA that
make this absolutely tight up to a
factor okay so this a really cool error
Bound for l
chose but it's often not good enough
this uniform error bound almost always
fails to actually capture the
performance of Lantos in practice if you
plot the error that you're getting out
of the method it's usually way way
better than this uniform error Val I'll
show you a picture in a minute and so
this is the entire point of this line of
work is to understand why this error
bound is not capturing what's happening
in practice and to give better error
bounds and better error bounds are going
require some different notion of
optimality because we know this error
bound's tight in the worst case so by
better error bounds I'm going to I want
to look at error bounds that for
specific A and B give you better bounds
than just the worst
case Okay so just as an
example so you're gonna bring back bring
it back in yeah yeah so note that like
this error bound doesn't depend on B
which already tells you it could be kind
of loose in some sense um the Airbound
also doesn't depend on the actual I
values of a it only depends on the range
of igen values which if people have run
like ucg like you know that the
convergence depends a lot on the
Spectrum the shape of the spectrum not
just its range so this is another reason
why this is like
loose so just as like an example Tyler
was just gave some examples of running
Lanos on a bunch of Matrix functions
like eight to the -2 exponential square
root this High Line is the uniform error
bound and then there's two lines here
that are pretty that look pretty close
to each other one is what Lantos
actually does and then one is the
optimal approximation of the Krill off
Subspace which you get by just Computing
The Matrix function exactly and then
projecting it to the krof Subspace so
this is sort of the best you could hope
for but it's non an efficient
solution they look like overlapping but
if you if you plot the relative error
here it's like always pretty small like
worst case Lantos at most in this case
like 1.5 or two times the optimal so
this is the type of behavior we want to
explain why is lantro following this
curve rather than that curve and what is
a here G or something yeah generally the
holding is rotational invariant so like
even diagonal a is the same as if you
did like random uh igen vectors so it is
I don't remember exactly what he set the
Spectrum to here it's probably like a
uniform Spectrum or like some sort of
uniform Spectrum the V vectors are are
yeah they don't matter yeah so you could
think of them as being random or
actually I think these are literally run
on diagonal a because then we avoid
conditioning we avoid like roundoff
error so we usually run it on diagonal
when we're doing the
test just just for the previous
slide sorry just I just want to make
sure I got the quantifi so for any
continuous function and K there exists
an A and B such that the error is at
least two of the that's exactly and what
you basically do is you exhibit um in
this in the in we actually Pro this in
this was kind of known for CG like for
solving systems we just extend this to
any continuous function in in like our
paper um you just basically can solve
for this worst case A and B that match
this bound you look at the equal
oscillating points of the best
polinomial
approximation thanks other
questions I'm sad I'm kind of low on
time I know I'm gonna run out of time
but we we'll get through as much as we
can and please ask questions because I
don't really want to rush so what do we
want to show we want to prove instance
optimality balance
we want to show that for like common
Matrix functions f um that we have a
bound which is basically that Lantos the
output of Lanos is within some
approximation factor C of the best
possible output which means the best
degree k polinomial for approximating
our function when applied to B so here
we're taking into account A and B not
just the pectal range and of of a and
another way to think about this this
would be the same as this was the same
as this this dotted line here this is
basically the error you get from exactly
Computing The Matrix function and
projecting it to your kof Subspace which
is inefficient
okay
um this type of instance optimality
guarantee if you ignored the C which
will be relevant obviously is always at
most the uniform approximation bound but
it's often smaller by a wide margin as
we can see from like these previous
plots it's usually much much
far now in the linear system case people
might already know that CG outputs
something that is optimal just not in
the two Norm but actually in the a norm
like the energy Norm so if you just
convert it to the two Norm this is known
to hold for f ofx being one overx where
C is square root of the condition number
or it's hold for it holds for C equals
one in the a norm is how people usually
think about
it there's some like partial guarantees
for the Matrix exponential shown by dren
Green bomb
and um but I'm not going to write them
down because they're kind of messy but
they're kind of getting at some sort of
instance optimality guarantee but prior
to artw work we weren't really aware of
any other known results for really
important functions like Matrix sign
function square root Etc so the whole
goal of our line of work is to basically
prove these types of bounds for other
important Matrix functions other than
just the inverse and my goal of giving
this talk is to convince you to try to
prove these things we make some really
minor progress basically we show really
bad bounds for rational functions which
is like a slight extension of X I would
like you to show better bounds for
broader classes of functions
basically so what is our result I mean I
don't mean to trash our result it
actually is gives something nice but
let's just State what it is I have a
rational function it's a degree mq
rational function so it's a degree m
polinomial p on top of a degree q
polinomial and the poles of this
rational function meaning the roots of
the stuff in the denominator which is
basically where the function could blow
up to Infinity the polls are going to
lie outside of my igen value range um
this kind of makes sense like if I have
polls in my igen value range bad things
could happen my function could go to
Infinity on my igen values and I'm not
going to get any good approximation
although if I have time I will mention
we have some results when poles are in
the igen value range an example of polls
being in the igen value range a really
simple example is the function one overx
when your Matrix is not PSD right uh
your IG value range includes zero but
the function goes to Infinity at zero
and there's actually some really cool
connections that you can get between
rational functions in solving uh non-psd
systems with things like Midas so I'll
talk about that hopefully again I'm GNA
Define ai to be just a shifted by my ith
pole
okay what we show is that Lanos is
instance optimal for such a rational
function where my approximation factor
is basically Q that's my number of poles
or the degree of the
denominator times the product of the
condition number of these shifted a okay
now there's a slight caveat specifically
K needs to be bigger than M the max of M
and Q minus one so it needs to be bigger
than the maximum of the degree on the
top and the degree on the bottom this is
a really mild condition because usually
M and Q minus one we're thinking of as
relatively small constants so the number
of iterations Will almost always be
bigger than this right um the second
other small caveat is we don't actually
compete with the best approxim
we compete with the best approximation
of a slightly lower degree so it's kind
of like a by criteria approximation so
we compete with the best degree K minus
q+ one approximation again it's pretty
mild if you're running 100 iterations
and Q is five you're competing with the
best 9 95 or 96 iteration algorithm so
it's pretty mild but it is a slight
relaxation of what we wanted to
show any questions just on the
de
just wanted to check so this this
implies something for General functions
too by first approximating with the
rational function or yeah I I I'll say
that on the next slide I'm not going to
write anything formal down but yeah why
do we care about rational well actually
wait any other questions before I move
on to sort of some remarks on
this okay yeah let me make some remarks
on this so why do we care about rational
functions um they're interesting in
their own right they can include one
overx and like for one overx this will
match up to some small like tweaks it
will kind of give you the instance
optimality of
CG uh it will be slightly worse than the
na proof but it also includes things
like one overx SAR this was the first
function we looked at we were like we
know that Lantos is optimal for one
overx is it optimal for one overx squ
like it's really not that big of an
extension so it includes those types of
really simple functions so this is one
motivation for looking at rational
functions other important motivation for
looking at rational functions is that
they often give really accurate
approximations to functions that have
discontinuities uh much better than like
polinomial do so this includes functions
like square root or step functions and
stuff have really good rational
approximates so I'm not going to write
anything down in this talk but you can
use our error bound to give stronger
error bounds for Lantos and
approximating functions that can be
approximated with rational functions via
some sort of triangle inequality type
argument so exactly what you're saying
um
something to note is that our
approximation factor C is really bad
notably it scales exponentially in Q so
even if all your PS were at zero our
approximating factor is like Q cap the Q
okay we think this can be
improved the best empirical lower bound
we have no theoretical lower bounds but
we have simulation showing that we can
make the approximation Factor as bad as
square root of Q Kappa but I mean
there's a big gap there so we couldn't
make it grow exponentially in Q so this
is a a question can you get our error
bound to better even with our bad error
bound the error bound gets much closer
to approximating uh I mean you know
explaining the behavior of Lanos than
the uniform bound does so in some sense
these plots are kind of silly like this
is the optimal bound and this is R bound
and since it's a log plot R bound is
just shifted up by whatever C is but you
can see that RB bound is much much less
than the uniform error bound um in many
reasonable circumstances so even though
we have a pretty bad error bound it's
often much tighter than the uniform
error but it could be tightened which I
think would be
nice this is for rational functions
these are all for rational functions the
second two rational functions are
rational approximates to the exponential
and the log because these are the types
of things that show up in
practice on this
slide I show I'm not going to talk about
these in the talk but as Kevin was
asking we derive error bounds for things
that are well approximated IR rational
functions so I'm plotting some of our
error bounds for um
square root an inverse Square Root
versus what was previously known the
uniform error bounds and they're also
tighter so this is another reason to
care about
Ral all right
so let's see I have like two minutes
left I was gonna try let me try to
sketch the proof really quickly so what
I'm going to first do is just sketch and
if I only get through this it's fine
just going to sketch the proof for why
is Lantos optimal for f ofx being one
overx this is where we start from trying
to prove that it's optimal for rational
functions okay
so people may have seen this
before basically if I look at the
difference between the actual solution
to the linear system and the lric
approximation if I multipli through by
like a to the one2 I basically can upper
bound this by square root of Lambda Max
of a that's for multiplying by a to the
one2 times like the whole thing where I
now have a to thetive one2 be a to the
one2 times the
approximation and what I can do is I can
just just expand out t as Q transpose
AQ um and then I can write b as a to the
12 a to 1 half and the magical thing
here is that
this this operator sitting here is just
the L2 projector of a to the negative2 B
onto a to the2
Q so this here is actually an optimal
solution to a linear regression problem
I can write this as basically the Min of
basically a 12 Q *
xus like a 12 this is anorm projection
onto the kof Subspace but I didn't want
to really use the a
norm if I just multiplied through again
by a to negative one2 I lose this one
overare root of Lambda Min but I get the
actual best approximation to my system
in the krof Subspace which is what I
wanted and so basically this is exactly
the same as an instance optimal
guarantee where the preactor like square
root of Kaa okay if you've seen this
before how this is usually worded is
that Lantos computes the aor norm
optimal approximation of a inverse B in
the krof Subspace a norm and two Norm
are equivalent up to a square root of
Capa factor and this gives this
directly
okay now the main idea on how to
generalize the rational functions is
really everything just once you can do
one overx squ you can do a lot of messy
algebra and do all these other rational
functions so I'm only going to look at
One overx S
here we use triangle inequality we look
at the error of Lanos we split it into
two different errors one is the error of
the exact Matrix function minus this
funny thing which would be like if I
applied Lanos to do one of my inverses
but then I exactly applied the other
inverse and then here is basically if I
just apply Lantos to do both inverses
versus if I apply Lantos to do one
inverse versus exactly applying the
other one so I just split it this
way the first term term you can show via
the same argument as on the previous
side that this is actually the best
approximation to a -2b in the span of
the krov Subspace in the a norm and so
following what I just did on the
previous slide this is basically within
opt up to a square root of Kappa Factor
okay so this term is kind of
easy the second term is a little bit
more
funny first what I can do is I can pull
out a qt1 q so I do that and then I have
this approximation term here the
spectron norm of qt1 Q is at most like 1
over Lambda Min and then this term here
that's just the lantro approximation to
the inverse so this is at most like
square root of Capa times the best
approximation to the inverse but that's
not what I wanted I wanted the best
approximation to 1/x^2 not to the
inverse the key idea is that the optimal
error for approximating the inverse with
degree K can be bounded by the optimal
error for approximating a -2 with degree
K minus one because if I had some good
approximation to a
-2 I could just multiply it by a and I
get a good approximation to the inverse
there's no way that approximate A2 is
significantly easier than approximating
a negative one because I can derive an
approximation of the inverse from the
other so basically like I don't have
time to do the actual math but I relate
this opt to my actual opt and lose like
a Lambda Max Factor when I do
that and overall this gives like some
capita of three Hales Factor times
actual op so I'm like overtime so I'll
just conclude basically this is the
analysis I just add these two things
together and in the case of a -2 I get
like two cap of three halves times my
actual opt the key idea was just
relating the optimal approximation the
inverse with the optimal approximation
to a
negative2 okay so I'll just conclude
with some open questions first open
question is tighten our bounds or shoot
or Sho or show stronger lower bounds so
as I mentioned our numerical lower
bounds which we hav impr proven are way
far away from our theoretical upper
bounds it would be cool to extend our
results to the case when the function
has poles in the spectral range in this
case lro seems to oscillate between very
bad and near Optimal Solutions and and
not only does it seem to it definitely
must do this but we can actually explain
this in the case of one overx so if we
can actually relate the convergence of
conent gradient to the midz algorithm
and show that this oscillatory behavior
is necessary but that you always
oscillate to a good solution and it
would be really cool to show this
General rational
functions um proving instance optimality
of Matrix exponential which would extend
the work of druskin at all proving
instance optimality bounce for Matrix
square root Etc there's a lot of sort of
open questions
here and then the final thing is
understanding the role of finite
Precision so we know that finite
Precision matters a lot here for cant
gradient this instance optimal bound is
completely dependent on your precision
and we have very little understanding we
don't even have a lot of understanding
the conun graning case Cas to be honest
so anyways doing anything with finite
Precision would be really interesting so
that's it thanks for your
time I think uh so that we have a little
break we should take questions
offline but we have another uh exciting
discussion session coming up at quarter
p and this time we'll hear from
[Music]
and is like Tom